grab some dragon meat and a nice bottle
of sapachika because
it's finally here the latest episode of
the mandalorian or as i like to call it
the only reason i still have a disney
plus subscription
in this video we'll be going over all
the cool details you might have missed
like what that object was the tuscans
pulled out of the dragon
cob vance boba fett armor and of course
that insane reveal but before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe with
that bell on as i plan on covering every
episode of the season
the last we saw of mando and the child
they were taking off in the razor crest
in search of baby yoda's people
a mission tasked to him by the armorer
who we got to see kick some ass at the
end of season one
they've landed on a new planet in search
of gor koresh an alien from the abyssin
species
you may remember seeing one of them in a
new hope when luke and obi-wan meet han
solo in the cantina gore is voiced by
john leguizamo and mando thinks he may
have some leads where he can find his
fellow mandalorians
they watch a battle between two
gomorians a species you may remember
from return of the jedi
and it isn't long before mando is held
at gunpoint for his precious best car
armor
something gorsuch the price of has gone
through the roof but mando uses his
whistling birds small guided missiles
which he obtained from the armorer in
episode 3 of season 1
as well as his mandalorian dagger known
as a cow to make quick work of gore and
his thugs
tracking him down and stringing him up
using his grappling line
mando finds out that gore knows of one
mandalorian hidden away on a small town
on tatooine called mos
pelgo mando thinks that's odd since he's
been on tatooine before and never heard
of any mandalorian being there he
actually visited tatooine back in season
1 episode 5
and we'll get to how the reveal at the
end of that episode
ties into the reveal at the end of this
one and in true mando fashion he leaves
gore to fend for himself against these
red-eyed creatures
and makes his way to tatooine where we
reunite with peli motto
she recalls how he hates droids droids
killed his parents after all but he's
had a change of heart
well so he likes droids now a result of
how a droid like ig-11
sacrificed himself at the end of season
one pelly tells mando that moss pelgo
was wiped out by bandits and can barely
be found on any maps we even get a nice
reintroduction to
r5d4 the droid the jawas tried to sell
to luke in a new hope she also makes
reference to a city on tatooine called
moss espa which you might remember as
the site of the pod races in the phantom
menace
mando grabs a speeder and heads off to
this mysterious mining town of moss
pelgo arriving like he's a gunslinger or
samurai in a kurosawa movie except a
horse has been substituted for a speeder
at the local cantina he meets the
proprietor from the weekway species
another race found in return of the jedi
there he meets the town's marshal which
also happens to be the title of the
episode he's a man by the name of cobb
vanth played by timothy oliphant and
he's wearing boba fett's armor the last
we saw boba fett he was thrown into the
sarlacc pit in return of the jedi so
this armor basically confirms he somehow
made it out
and we'll get to that reveal later in
the episode he tells mando he got it off
some jawas in exchange for a chem tono
of silicax crystals
something he stole from the minders
after escaping their attack on the town
after the fall of the empire if you want
to learn a little bit more about what a
camp tono is
check out my season 1 episode 1 of
breakdown this isn't the first time
cobb vanth has been seen in the star
wars universe chuck wendig's star wars
canon novel
aftermath features him arguing over a
set of mandalorian armor and includes
further backstory involving how he
fights against crime syndicates
disguising themselves as
mining companies after the fall of the
hot cartel he'll later use the
mandalorian armor to drive the miners
out of his town so we can see why he
won't easily give it up
and it's totally awesome that we
actually get to see his missile in
action and it looks like a good
old-fashioned duel will take place
between mando and cobb to decide who
will get this precious armor but they're
interrupted by an earthquake caused by a
giant krait dragon believe it or not
you've probably seen one of these
dragons before well
at least the skeleton of one as it's
seen in the background in a new hope
this giant sand reptile's been plaguing
the town and even eats an entire bantha
krayt dragons are native to tatooine and
hunted for their precious pearls that's
what we see at the end of the episode
when the tuscans carve up its carcass
freight dragons were known to digest
stones to assist in their digestion and
sometimes in rare occasions
these stones would contain kyber
crystals the same crystals used to make
lightsabers over
time they'd form into these smooth
pearls making them extremely valuable
comp and mando make a deal if mando
helps to kill the creature
cobb will give up his armor cobb and
mando enlists the help of local tuscan
raiders to take on the dragon an
alliance which doesn't sit well with the
local populace
you might recognize cobb's speeder here
which is made from an
engine that anakin used in the pod races
in the phantom menace the tuscans had
raided moss pelgo in search of water
which apparently they were stealing in
this
way both groups aren't really seen as
the bad guy both of them are just doing
what they have to to provide for their
people
in an act of friendship the tuscans give
cobb a black melon an egg-shaped fruit
native to the jungle and wastes of
tatooine which contains milk milk that
obi-wan said tasted horrible
and that cobb refuses to drink it stinks
mando and the raiders try to lure the
dragon out of an abandoned sarlacc pit
these things
eat sarlacc the tuscans have been
feeding the crate for years in an
attempt to keep it sleeping and stopping
it from plaguing their villages
if they're gonna get this thing out
they're gonna need more people
and that's where the villagers of moss
pelgo come in the crate dragon has been
a
nuisance for the town eating their
animals and disrupting their mining
halls
and it could be any day that it totally
swallows the town whole so they decide
to join forces with the tuscans
providing much needed explosives to take
it down you may also have noticed that
during the final dragon sequence the
aspect ratio changes to full screen i'm
not 100 certain of the specs but it
probably meant this
action sequence was shot in imax and
what better way to welcome jon favreau
his first directing gig on the show
by giving him and us this awesome treat
the tuscans say that dragon's only weak
spot is its belly so if they can lure it
out on top of the explosives maybe they
stand a chance at killing it they do
everything they can to get its attention
but their barrage of ballista
blasters and grenades isn't enough the
explosives go off but it only infuriates
the dragon further
vomiting out its carosa bile at its
attackers
its care pace is just too strong even
for the explosives so mando takes
matters into his own hands by
luring the dragon next to a bantha
loaded with dynamite even knocks cobb's
jetpack to make him get out of the way
even telling cobb beforehand to take
care of the child he's willing to
sacrifice himself for this the dragon
completely swallows both mando and the
bantha but a few moments later spits
mando out after he uses his ammon phase
pulse blaster
which has an electrocution feature we
saw him use this briefly in season 1
against the trandoshan bounty hunters
mando hits the detonator the dragon
explodes and 10 year old me watching
tremors for the first time
jumps for joy you sucker
with the dragon defeated cobb hands over
the armor and tells mando he hopes their
paths cross again so this might not be
the last time we see him he also says to
tell his fellow mandalorians that he
wasn't the one to break that armor that
was likely caused by the sarlacc however
we do not know what happened between
boba fett getting thrown into the pit
and how it eventually ended up with the
jawas perhaps that will be revealed
with the introduction of boba fett
himself the end of the episode sees
actor tamura morrison who played
jango fett in the prequels reveal
himself as boba fett remember that jango
was allowed to keep one of his clone
sons to raise on his own this was boba
fett who would grow up to look
exactly like jango since he's a clone it
raises many
questions like why he's been in hiding
and how or why he let his armor go
he's got a couple scars on his face so
he's been through a lot
he's also been following mando and his
adventures on tatooine the end of
episode 5 sees a
tattered robe figure hover over the
corpse of fenik shan
a tattered robe which boba also wears at
the end of this episode for those of you
who've seen my season 1 episode 5
breakdown
you'll remember that the same boot spur
sound effect used for that robed
character is the same exact sound effect
used when boba fett walks in empire
strikes back check out the 9 minute and
30 second marker in that video if you
want to hear it for yourself
i'll leave a link in the description a
particular note in this episode is the
absence of moff gideon who we saw
survive his crash and emerge from his
ship holding a dark saber
unfortunately we're gonna have to wait a
bit longer to have him back and i
wouldn't be surprised if part of next
episode continues on tatooine
especially knowing mando is likely on a
crash course with boba fett
whether or not he's friend or foe
remains to be seen
thanks for watching everyone every
little like subscribe and share helps so
much so
make sure to do that for more bad takes
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thinkstoryyt and until next time
remember
i have spoken